so
what you are looking at right now is a
visual effect shot no one has been able
to do before oh come on Ren this is a
clone shot it's one of the easiest
effects to do okay perhaps but Nico
notice how the camera is moving yeah but
we've had motion control robot arms for
a while what makes this shot so special
well for the first time a motion
controlled Cinema Camera can fly
[Music]
okay so to understand why this is a big
deal let's rewind all the way back to my
very first VFX shot 17 years ago look at
little baby me this type of effect is so
easy you can use any video editing
software just take a camera and put it
on a tripod or a desk table it doesn't
matter
then just record a shot we're on one
half of the screen then just film
another shot where on the other half of
the screen and by cropping the footage
and laying it on top of the other shot
in the edit you achieve a final effect
that's that easy just careful not to
move the camera or else the effect
starts falling apart this effect can get
more advanced pretty quickly depending
on how much rotoscoping you want to do
but that's not really that hard it just
takes a lot of time for a really complex
version of this effect let's look at the
old school quarter film clock blockers
Sam and Nico are able to clone
themselves into moving footage by using
motion tracking now you have to track
one shot into another to achieve this
effect however this technique only works
if the position of your camera is locked
you can still aim it up and down left
and right and whatnot but you can't move
it through 3D space if you want to do
that you need a friggin robot
[Music]
mama
these very cool Cinema robots are so
precise they can repeat any motion you
program into them again and again and
again allowing for different shots to
seamlessly be comped together this is
called motion control and has actually
been around for decades in fact we
actually broke down how motion control
made the original Star Wars possible in
an episode of visual effects artists
react like in the description but as
cool as robot arms are they still have a
major limitation they can only move the
camera as far as the arm can reach and
sure you can get more range of motion by
putting the entire robot on a dolly
track but there's still a limit to how
far it can move and that is why I am so
excited about the opening shot to this
video because For the First Time precise
motion control is possible on a cinema
drone thanks to the DJI Inspire 3. this
video is sponsored by DJI so let's talk
about this drone real quick this is
super Sleek look these controllers the
controllers are nuts I've never seen
like a controller so beefy let's say
you're flying the Drone I could be
operating the gimbal this gimbal can
actually look upwards which was not
possible on any other drone before this
oh you're right there's no drone in the
way so if you're gonna have a camera
integrated into your drone it's got to
be a good camera right exactly
sir is a full
sir that shoots a resolution in prores
raw or Cinema dng wow but else also has
14 stops of dynamic range really 13 to
14 stops is where you cross into the
dynamic range needed for like Cinema
production and what's the battery life
on this when you're flying 28 minutes
Non-Stop and the fact that there are two
separate batteries running in parallel
means that you can hot swap them without
turning off the Drone you can keep all
your systems running which will save you
time and when you're on a professional
film set time is literally everything so
this camera actually has a native ISO at
800 but also at 4 000 that means this
has dual native isos what does that mean
though native ISO yeah the iso is
basically your exposure rating for how
sensitive your sensor is in the native
ISO is where the sensor is getting equal
amount of exposure down below the
midpoint an equal amount of exposure up
above the midpoint you know I thought I
understood what Native ISO was but I
guess I didn't so this means you can
actually shoot at night with really
really good quality we haven't even
talked about the transmission of this
thing because this is a wireless camera
how far does it go red it's rated for I
think 15 km kilometers which is almost
it's like nine miles of range a
responsible pilot is not going to be
flying nine miles out that's very
irresponsible it's more about having the
power when you need it to like film for
like a building or something exactly
exactly this is a strong enough signal
and a clear enough signal that it can
transmit to two controllers at the same
time nuts it's super nuts with like
almost no lag so this is utilized in the
new 03 pro video transmission system
which they've you know fully integrated
into the Ronin line wow DJI a cohesive
ecosystem so outside of just being a
really good cinema drone I heard there's
some tech in here that lets us get an
effect shot people have never been able
to get before yes so this has a whole
real life keyframing ability in it
called Waypoint Pro and you can set like
a point a and then a point B and the
Drone will be able to autonomously fly
between those points and be able to nail
the exact same camera move over and over
again what is that that is motion
control
[Music]
I'm gonna hit create auto add Waypoint
and I'll put this down
and it should just do it look at that
it's just flying on its own right now so
flying drone flight mission complete I'm
gonna suggest we move over here and I'm
gonna do it one more time one more the
end result of this will be three little
groups of us just chilling next to each
other without even carrying that we got
clones we're the only clones waving
don't listen to them shoot him shoot him
it never quite lined up well enough you
know with proper like robotic motion
control every single Pixel is like
perfect and that's kind of the
limitation of GPS a little bit too it is
yeah the reason why this for the first
time ever is really actually taking that
to the next level is due to one thing a
wizard staff
this is now going to relay a bunch of
information to the Drone and the reason
why that's a big deal is because now it
gives the Drone centimeter level
accuracy about where it is in 3D space
wow so now it actually does feel like a
robot arm in the sky
now that you understand what it took to
get here let's go get that opening shot
this is how you do motion control with a
drone first you set up your rtk system
design your camera routes and then once
we get to about right here that's when
it's your turn to start ripping then you
lift off your drone once you got the
Drone up in the air you got to set your
waypoints so that we get a solid good
camera move I'm set all right Nico take
off now you can actually just do it over
and over again have your clones in
different spots or do whatever you want
with the shot I'm the middle guy dude
this is so cool oh my God I'm not even
doing anything I'm just standing here
this is so cool
I'm getting a real appreciation for
stop-motion control from back in the day
when they'd have to shoot everything
onto film and it would take days to see
if these expensive models that you blew
up all lined up and moved correctly but
we'll know by Monday if these shots all
line up
it's flawless I can't see any flaws let
me show you what I had to do to make
this work so there's slight
synchronization issues so all I had to
do was literally just throw a bunch of
position keyframes with a little bit of
rotoscoping this whole shot works
perfectly so this is an aerial motion
control shot I've never seen one of
these before in my life and I see a lot
of visual effects this works it looks
like a normal clone shot at first but
then it moves in a way we've just we've
never seen clone shots move before when
you have a repeatable camera move like
this the movement is very strict it
doesn't allow for any sort of like
Improv and if you want to have a little
bit of that in your scene you can't use
motion control but DJI actually has a
new system called 3D dolly that brings
in some improv in the flight you can
take that point A to point B and have
that move between them be variable and
it's super simple to find it's literally
just holding forward on a stick or
backwards on the stick to quote Morpheus
show me
staff has been placed and I'll have you
run out to here and curve left and now
you're going down the sidewalk
don't get too close to it demonstrate
good drone safety
what gonna set up the Waypoint upload
flight Mission and start that's so wild
dude this is like a complex camera move
that I'm piloting without actually
piloting so just pressing forward to
make it go that's crazy how accurate it
is yeah I want to have a moment where
you stop and you're on the phone you're
like what and you realize you got to
move okay that's something that you
can't do it's just a programmed camera
move all right action oh held up hold up
hold up
got a car here so I can actually make it
go backwards I've already started the
camera move but I just hit back and I
pushed the dolly back it only goes when
you push it ready yep and action wait
what do you mean I'm auditioning to be a
stunt of over Tom Cruise they're
watching me right now they want to see
how much I can Sprint all right
[Music]
FedEx
that's really cool the first half of the
shot I was going kind of slow and right
before you started running I just like
floored it I floored it and it started
going now check this out I'm gonna do a
reverse camera move I'm gonna make it
come back the way it went oh that's so
cool
that's really accurate actually it's
like having a cable camera watching it
do the same past fours and backwards
like it's a 3D animated camera but in
real life floating in front of you yeah
I'm beginning to see what you mean about
this letting us do an effect shot that
has never been done before oh I've got
an idea Nico that's really cool
streaming
a playback right now raw by the way so I
made a camera move that is five key
frames long and using a spreadsheet here
just subtracted
.0007 from the latitude about the width
of the highway so that way by manually
inputting the longitude and latitude for
each of those points the entire path is
displaced by about 60 feet each time I
should end up with a super megawatt
highway that has never seen the light of
day on this planet let's head back up to
the north
and it's going
[Music]
huh
crap crap
[Laughter]
all right I'm gonna land it the shots
are in the can the next thing to do is
to import the footage and start layering
them up
[Music]
God this is sick she just keeps yelling
it's amazing this is insane it looks
natural enough that like people could be
like oh yeah no that's that's just a
highway in somewhere in the world right
some people probably think this is where
the highways in La look like I promise
you they're not that wrong
the sun is perfectly reflecting off all
of the highways correctly it's just
masking that's all it is some of the
most basic visual effects work you can
do but with the right sort of planning
in the right
and the right that enables it cool stuff
like this can now exist and that makes
me happy
[Music]
so we're done getting what we plan to
get here and now we're literally in the
middle of golden hour dude this thing is
so sick I was just doing that for fun so
much fun you want to see what a broken
collarbone looks like I did it less than
a week ago
I'm getting surgery next week so it's
like
I don't care about Comfort right now
this goes over my head I broke it again
it's the other collarbone this time yes
I was wondering like shut up that's why
I'm not really one Wheeling too much but
all this flying has like totally
reinvigorated my love for flying I
haven't really flown much over the last
year
so
this is great so I'm just gonna fly
around and just get some more shots
[Music]
all right
thank you so much for watching I love
experimenting with new cameras new
technology drones oh my God I love it so
much I've actually linked a playlist to
a whole bunch of videos that I've made
experimenting with that stuff I've made
a whole freaking Snyder cam three
different iPhones filming slow-mo at the
same time check that video out right now
made a whole bunch of other things I put
cameras on all kinds of stuff cars dogs
footballs cannons
check it out you'll have a good time
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
next one